now why is it that you think
that you're the first astronomer to come
out with some some fascinating stuff
like this
talking about the umua and talking about
interstellar potential
extraterrestrial objects right over our
solar system
well uh first i should mention you know
that this subject is
uh at the periphery of astronomy it's
not funded much
and anyone that talks about the search
for technological signatures is sort of
marginalized
uh sometimes to the point where
the subject is ridiculed and that is
unfortunate because it doesn't bring
it doesn't allow new talent to enter the
field
or to get funded for doing research in
this
in this field and it's sort of like
stepping on the grass and then saying
look it doesn't grow so obviously we
don't get
major discoveries or important results
because of the uh this self-fulfilling
prophecy that the fact that the
community is not supporting it
and i find this to be completely
inappropriate because the public is
extremely interested in the question
are we alone i'm interested in the
question beyond that because i think
that we are probably not alone
you know half of the sun-like stars have
a planet the size of the earth
roughly at the same separation so you
have billions of earth sun
system just within the milky way galaxy
our own galaxy
and then you have a trillion galaxies
like the milky way
within the observable volume of the
universe so altogether
you know there are more earth sun
systems than the numbers of grains of
sand
on all beaches on earth it's just huge
and the chance that we're special or
unique is really
minute and out of modesty
we should consider the possibility that
things like us exist
everywhere as the the simplest
assumption you know most conservative
assumption
if you replicate the same circumstances
you get the same outcome
but for some reason the mainstream
community prefers
not to think that way and say you know
maybe we are unique maybe we are special
you need
extraordinary evidence in order to argue
otherwise
i would argue that you need
extraordinary evidence to assume that we
are unique
because whenever we thought that we were
special we were wrong
you know in the past we thought that we
are the center of the universe
aristotle suggested that in his
philosophy
and for a thousand years people believed
it until copernicus and galileo
demonstrated that the earth moves around
the sun
and even then the philosophers at the
time didn't like the idea
they didn't look through galileo's
telescope and they just maintained their
ignorance
uh you know that reality doesn't care
about whether we ignore it or not
and whenever we assume that we are
unique and special we were wrong
it's sort of like my daughters when they
were infants
um you know they thought that they are
unique they have qualities that nobody
else has
and they're at the center of the world
but once they went to a kindergarten
they saw other kids and they got a
better perspective
so for us as the human species as
civilization to mature we need to find
others
and get a better perspective about our
place in the universe
but many people prefer you know it
flatters their ego
to maintain the view that we are alone
until proven differently and i find that
to be completely
opposite to where they should be but by
preventing
any research in this subject by
ridiculing uh
suggestions that we might not be alone
uh
you know you don't get anyone to work on
that
and that's why i'm sort of alone
standing against this mainstream and i
should say you know i'm not
an outlier i i've worked in the
mainstream for many years i had
a lot of leadership positions i was the
longest serving chair of the astronomy
department at harvard
between 2011 to 2020 nine years
a position that was renewed twice and
i'm the chair of the board on physics
and astronomy of the national academies
and at the same time i think that the
current view
is misguided and i think that this
subject appeals to the public
and the public funds science and
therefore we have an obligation to
address it
with existing tools that we have
telescopes and instruments
and we can do it just to give you an
example
you know the astronomers are developing
the next generation of instruments
to search for uh and these would cost
billions of dollars to search for oxygen
for example
in the atmospheres of planets around
other stars because the idea is that
oxygen will tell us if there is life on
these planets
around other stars the problem with this
idea
is that oxygen was rare did not exist
in the earth atmosphere
at noticeable levels for two billion
years for half of the lifetime of the
earth for the first two billion years
there wasn't much much oxygen in the
atmosphere but there was life on earth
there were microbes so not finding
oxygen
is not evidence that life doesn't exist
also
finding oxygen is not evidence that life
exists because you can make it
by natural processes and
if you ask yourself what would be a
conclusive signature
of life is if we find industrial
pollution
in those atmospheres those molecules
that are very complex and
are produced by the industries that we
have
or by refrigerating systems they're
called cfcs
if we do find evidence for those then we
know that life might
must exist so in fact uh the
justification to the future the next
generation of instruments that
astronomers are developing
is much stronger in the context of the
search for technological signatures than
it is
in the search for primitive life but
nevertheless
you would never find an argument or a
motivation for these instruments in that
context
what sort of conversations have you had
or debates have you had with with your
colleagues or other astronomers when it
comes to the pushback that you've
received
from being outspoken about things like
this and the the muammua and intelligent
life
well i can give you an example there was
a seminar about the um
harvard and uh when i left the room with
a colleague of mine that worked on the
solar system for decades
he said this object is so weird
i wish it never existed and that
illustrates to you that
the properties of this object take peop
take people away
from their comfort zone and
most people prefer not to change uh
their views and not not to update
uh what they thought to be
[Music]
the world view uh of that describes the
universe and
you know it's sort of like um a gps
system when it gets to a place that it
doesn't
recognize it says recalculating
uh and unfortunately most of my
colleagues do not recalculate
they just want to maintain their views
so most of the mainstream
would simply say business as usual
i don't care about the details it must
be a rock
to me that sounds just like a caveman
saying that when presented with a cell
phone
you know the caveman is used to work you
know playing with rocks all of his life
saying oh the cell phone is just a shiny
rock
and the point of the matter is since i
don't find intel
uh technological signatures as a
speculation
i think it should be contemplated as a
real possibility put on the table
and then you know one can gather more
evidence
to try and and see if indeed it's
consistent with that and
uh it should not be dismissed up
dismissed up front
um and so um i think there needs to be a
revision
in the culture uh right now that within
the academic community
there are also parts of for example
physics the physics community
theoretical physics that engage in
concepts that cannot be tested
experimentally
such as extra dimensions or the
multiverse
or super sim super symmetry
or string theory these are concepts that
were not yet proven to be
correct based on experimental evidence
they are highly speculative
and for decades people have been working
on them and doing mathematical
gymnastics
or about demonstrating how smart they
are
but you know the doing physics is not
about showing off
as being smart it's about understanding
reality understanding nature and if
you're trying to do that
you should be guided by evidence yeah i
mean there's tons of there's tons of
money
that goes into things like the lhc that
they go to find the higgs boson and all
those other things
it's amazing that i would imagine and
correct me if i'm wrong
the number one thing on the checklist of
reasons to become an astronomer would be
to find
extraterrestrial life or to or to find
something
out there well in fact a lot of
physicists would
would say that they were
attracted to doing physics because they
rent read some science fiction stories
and
uh i think that this is the most
exciting question for us to address
because it will change our perspective
about our place in the universe our
aspirations for space and
uh it could impact um many things we do
uh including religious beliefs you know
and
uh and so um i think it's just a missed
opportunity for scientists if they have
the tools to address this question and
search for
technological signatures not to do that
and that's why i speak
speak out loud and i use omoamoa as an
anchor to demonstrate that here is an
anomalous object
that didn't look like anything we have
seen before and all the mainstream
suggestions for why
it looks so weird also invoked
something that we've never seen before
you know a hydrogen iceberg or a
cloud of dust and then
given that we are entertaining
possibilities that were never seen
before
why not also a technological origin it's
sort of like
you know walking on the beach and most
of the time you see rocks or sea shells
but every now and then you stumble
across a plastic bottle
that indicates that the civilization
might be around